[musique]
Ici on a vécu les plus beaux jours de notre vie, je veux dire, malgré ça
C'était une guerre et c'était très difficile pour nous, mais pourquoi ?
Nous avions l'habitude de venir dans cette salle, cette salle même
Même s'il faisait très sombre et qu'il faisait très sombre
Son quartier est un peu dangereux
[musique]
Une fois, nous nous entraînions ici à côté de notre père, d'accord ?
Il était sous la fenêtre et assis dans une coquille
Nous ne sommes pas rentrés chez nous sous Balabo
Au bout d'une heure, nous sommes revenus et avons terminé
Nous avons effectué un exercice normal et rien ne s'est passé
[musique]
Que Dieu bénisse son âme
Nous étions avec notre père et avons dit les choses les plus importantes jusqu'à la mort à laquelle tu as rendu visite
La coopération m'a répondu, ce qui signifie que vous avez fait plus pour nous
Ces missiles sont comme des missiles. Nous y répondons
pendant
À travers la civilisation qui existe encore à Alep
[musique]
Nous disons que la guerre est terminée en termes de destruction
Et l'Azarif, mais il y a encore une autre guerre, elle existe toujours
Ce que nous vivons est une guerre économique et une guerre psychologique
De nombreuses personnes ont voyagé, des familles ont immigré et ne sont pas encore revenues
À Alep
Bonjour, je n'ai pas l'impression que ce soit la guerre
J'ai fini
Je veux dire, nous n'avons pas encore fini, je n'ai pas fini de hurler à la guerre
Nous avons des résultats clairs, mais malheureusement pour le monde
Le monde entier a oublié Alep, le monde entier ne s'en soucie même plus
En Syrie
Aujourd’hui on se demande comment on peut sortir de tout ça
la situation
Comment pouvons-nous revenir en arrière et reconstruire ses murs ?
Nos âmes brisées
Comment pourrons-nous à nouveau vivre ensemble comme avant ?
J'ai confiance en cette chose et honnêtement, ça
La chose
[musique]
ma vie
Washington
Notre valeur
[musique]
Je t'aime
Et il y a de l'amour en nous
Oui
C'est mon meilleur ami et il chantait
On se connaît avant d'entrer dans la chorale
Nous chantons beaucoup ensemble et chantons chaque fois que nous nous sentons bien
On se voit et parfois on vient même ici
Couché
[musique]
Et réalisé
Par ta résurrection
George sait qu'un jour il partira
Ce pays voyagera, Dieu sait mieux, mais s'il voyage, c'est sûr
Il laissera une grande histoire dans mon cœur
[musique]
Oh Seigneur
Quand je vois
Une église qui existait auparavant
C'est un refuge pour nous de venir ici
Faire la fête, ressentir une ambiance intimiste
Je ne sais pas, c'est une sensation très étrange
En premier lieu, après l'avoir vue ainsi, j'ai oublié ce qui s'était passé avant
Je ne me souvenais plus de la photo
Dans ma tête, je suis triste, je veux dire, je m'énerve beaucoup
Pensez au voyage, vous quittez la Syrie, c'est-à-dire ma famille.
Dehors, mes sœurs sont dehors, et toute la famille est hors de ma famille
Aux Pays-Bas, mon frère est en Allemagne
Je suis là, mais Dieu me protège, je ne pense pas à sortir
Voyons quand tout ira bien, mais elle a commencé à réfléchir
que c'est
Après ça, il ne reste plus rien dans le pays
Tout va bien pour moi, j'ai des problèmes
Nous avons vécu ici dans un futur, mais nous aimons le chaos
Nous aimons les relations sociales
D'après ce que dit le monde entier, je suis selon ce qu'ils disent
Par exemple, les magasins étaient fermés et il ne restait plus personne
Obligatoire
Le ménage, et celui qui tire bien tombera
Badur, par exemple, est le rôle de Barat Al-Balad
Oh, bien sûr, ce ne sont que des paroles, je n'ai rien vu
[musique]
Quelqu'un a-t-il une nouvelle expérience en matière de santé, pourquoi ai-je une chance?
Jusqu'à ce que j'essaye mon âme
[Il rit]
[musique]
Dis, ouvre les yeux
Regarde regarde
C'était difficile dans cette ville avant
A part ça, il se passait de belles choses
Je me souviens de ce magasin, c'est ici qu'il se trouvait
C'est tout un magasin rond
Il y a un monde et les gens vont et viennent et voici ceux-ci
Les rues de cette place sont pleines de monde et ici
Abou Abdo Al-Fawal
Ce marché regorge de vendeurs de poisson
C'est difficile, c'est-à-dire sortir et voir quelque chose qui était là et ce qui n'était pas
C'est là-bas
Une chose très difficile, un travail difficile
[musique]
La chorale nous a aidés à traverser les jours de guerre
La musique est capable de destruction et de crise
Protégez-nous et protégez-nous de cette atmosphère chargée
La musique était le meilleur moyen de traverser la guerre
Elias était infirmier dans un hôpital pendant la guerre
Si vous êtes en bonne santé, vous l'avez déjà rencontré
J'ai entendu sa voix, sa voix est très douce et c'est comme ça qu'il chante
D'une manière très douce
Alors je lui ai dit : Elias, que penses-tu de nous rejoindre ?
le ballon
[musique]
Mazen vient du bus, un jeune homme occupé et ambitieux qui possède une boutique
Presque tous les jours, les téléphones portables viennent chez Sugar et viennent vers moi
Faire de l'exercice après le travail
Layla des Sopranos
Elle a raté
En dehors du pays, sa voix est très douce et elle aime beaucoup chanter
[musique]
Maria est la seule haine, tout le monde l'aime, elle est le cœur
Mère gentille et attentionnée envers tout le monde
[musique]
La chorale est devenue comme une autre famille que nous aimons tous
Certains d'entre nous se sont soutenus les uns les autres et nous nous soutenons mutuellement. Je veux dire, vous sentez que
Nous sommes une famille très unie, j'espère qu'un jour
Jours où nous délivrons notre message au monde entier
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Ce chœur en Syrie est le premier chœur de ce type
Il dit que la musique classique et d'Europe occidentale
Je veux dire, nous ici avons l'habitude de chanter et d'entendre nos propres hymnes
Province Orientale, notre père Elias, que Dieu lui fasse miséricorde
Parmi les nombreuses voix distinctes et brillantes du monde
La musique continuait toujours
Des personnes talentueuses avec des voix distinctes
Chœurs et églises pour être avec lui dans la chorale
Bonjour, quand j'étais jeune, j'étais à l'Institut Arabe
Pour la musique, j'y ai appris à jouer du violon
Depuis que je suis jeune, mon rêve est de manquer davantage
Je suis plus intéressé par le domaine de diffuseur, musicien et chanteur
Le chant ukrainien est comme ça quand j'ai réalisé qu'il s'agissait de nous
C'est une chorale ici à Alep quand j'étais un peu jeune
Ce rêve a un peu grandi avec moi
[musique]
séjourné
Toujours
Secouer
Oh Et sa résurrection
[musique]
Beaucoup de gens
Nos morts puent
Oh notre maître
[musique]
On se débarrasse de toute la haine, mais il y en avait beaucoup
Les personnes
[musique]
Bravo
Nous sommes très excités, monsieur
[musique]
Comment l’ont-ils restauré parce que nous sommes si jaloux ?
[Il rit]
[musique]
Il m'est très difficile aujourd'hui de voir comment le pays est devenu
Ce grand pays donné me rappelle une fête
Homs, j'étais très malade, et franchement, je n'ai pas pu m'en empêcher
En voyageant à Homs, je n'ai pas eu le courage
Je vois que cette belle ville a été détruite
Bienvenue aux voyageurs comme celui-ci, laissés seuls et désertés
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Où puis-je te mettre sur ma tête ?
[musique]
[applaudissements]
[Il rit]
[musique]
Avant, bienvenue
J'avais 18 ans, j'ai 24 ans, on est presque arrivé
Moyens
Sept ans : j'ai vécu sept ans de guerre
Toute mon enfance, malheureusement
[musique]
Il y a beaucoup de choses dans la guerre, on a beaucoup grandi, c'est nous
Bonjour, vingt signifie la même chose que 26 ans, je le ressens
J'ai l'impression d'avoir quarante ans
La seconde guerre est devenue très dure
Nerveux
Je veux dire, nous avons commencé à dire, par exemple, aujourd'hui nous sommes là
Nous vivons ce moment et demain cela nous sera permis
Ils existent
[musique]
Comme un rêve en tant que jeune homme de mon âge
Avancé sur mon appareil, avancé qu'il soit établi
Aaliya élève des enfants
Je pense qu'actuellement dans ce pays nous sommes malheureusement les mêmes
En tant que jeune, je parle
Le droit de manger, par exemple, un paquet de fumée
Mais à part ça, c’est difficile d’ouvrir une maison et difficile de fonder une famille
Tout est devenu difficile dans ce pays, si Dieu le veut
Ça va juste mieux
Ça fait sept ans qu'on est, donc ça fait encore deux ans, et puis son boulot
long
[musique]
En arabe, c'est comme Hiroshima, comment est-il tombé ?
Zut
Éclats
Et elle vit sa vie de chevalier pour les gens qu'elle était ici
Où sont-ils tous allés? Voyager autour du monde
Rien ne veut dire désert
Déserté, tu as remarqué
[musique]
Cela signifie que les patients
Je ne sais pas à quel point c'est raisonnable
C'est comme s'il y avait des ailes et mon système ressemble
[musique]
Allons-y
Écoute, va chez mon grand-père, mais je ne sais pas où
Comment puis-je y aller ?
la maison de mon grand-père
Une maison cadeau
A côté de moi se trouve un cuisinier
jordanien
Mais tous
Et je suis resté là
Non, pas ça, non, ça n'existait pas avant moi
Et son intoxicant est Talaat Al-Hamidiyya
il était
Ma mère
Yasmine, chaque fois que je sens Yasmine, je me souviens de son odeur
A
Bienvenue chez Maman, je veux dire, au dessus de la maison de mon oncle Samir
La maison de mon oncle, la maison de mon grand-père, a toujours été entre ses mains
L'imprimante d'Amara était entre ses mains, et au bout d'un moment il l'avait
jeunes
[applaudissements]
Avec les gémissements, personne ne l'oubliera sûrement
Ok, dernière chose
On ouvre l'église en coupant le ruban
Et enflammer les rôles
Nous prenons le cheval
[musique]
Temps de guerre à travers un groupe terroriste
Il y a des voix douces dans le monde de Jai Karmal
loin
[musique]
Pour la première fois, la colonne de support était mondiale, mais c'est tout
Cela m'est venu à l'esprit
Comment étions-nous avant et comment existons-nous maintenant ?
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Le Messie
Le roi est sa mort
Un dépôt
vie Hé
Reposons-nous dans la lumière lorsque nous rencontrerons ton visage
[musique]
On voit qu'il y a une stagnation ici, les gens se couchent
Et les étrangers
Peut-être qu'ils ne connaissent pas l'adresse de la Tchétchénie ou quoi que ce soit
Parce qu'ils sont grands et vêtus de blanc et portent des vêtements
Avec eux
arme
Ils ont créé l'horreur ici dans le quartier, alors nous nous sommes tous cachés
Nous sommes entrés par la fenêtre
J'ai juste sorti la tête et je voulais voir ce qui se passait
Cela arriverait ou non. Il est descendu vers moi, s'est levé et m'a dit d'entrer.
Citoyen, je veux dire, est-ce que quelqu'un parle l'arabe classique ?
De la part des gens du pays
La situation reste donc la même
Dans la soirée, l'armée est entrée et les chars sont arrivés.
C'est ici
Peut-être que neuf heures du soir signifie que la journée a été longue
Il est moche
Ceux qui entendent la prière, la prière leur est la bienvenue
prières
Il fait plusieurs prières pendant la journée dans son université
fermer
Nous entendons clairement la prière
prières
Nos frères islamiques
[musique]
Je veux dire, ce qui est bien c'est qu'il a pu coexister
Par exemple, dans la zone de l'église Hun de la mosquée Hun
Dans une école de religieuses, au bout d'un moment, dans une autre école
Mixte signifie que tout le monde était vivant
Il n'y a aucun problème et personne n'est dérangé par personne
Quelqu'un connaît ses limites et les traite humainement
Mais malheureusement, ils sont venus détruire l'humanité avec nous
Par leurs actions après cela, mais ce n'est pas une preuve que ce sont tous les gens
Comme eux, je veux dire, mais ils ont donné une idée terrible
Nous avons besoin de temps pour purifier nos cœurs
Et nos enfants qui ont vécu pendant cette période
C'est dur, je veux dire
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Et puis comme ça
La première fois, c'était aléatoire, c'est-à-dire dans des zones
Il nous est interdit d'y entrer
Tu es d'Alep, oui d'Alep
Pendant la crise, nous sommes restés ici à Alep, Dieu merci
Je veux dire, nous sommes restés fidèles jusqu'au dernier moment parce que j'étais là pour nous
Espoir et optimisme quant au fait qu’Alep restera telle qu’elle est
L'aéroport a été long, oh beau, viens, oh l'argent de Damas
Oh mon Dieu, mon argent est long, ma belle, viens non
Changez-vous ou changez-vous?
Tu me manques, Nour
mes yeux
[musique]
La première fois
Tu me manques, la lumière de mes yeux, jusqu'à ce que nous remontions le temps
Le premier, pour qu'on puisse revenir la première fois, allez
[Il rit]
La plupart des chansons sont Hdoul Hafzanin Alep, Syrie
Très à l'aise psychologiquement
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Un grand rêve dans lequel il me montrera à tout le monde dans lequel il se trouve
Nous avons des gens éduqués à Alep, des gens créatifs qui se soucient
Avec danse classique et musique de ballet
Nos jeunes, ici à Alep en particulier, sont pleins d'espoir et de passion.
Ils ont de nombreux plans et projets. Hikmet, par exemple, est diplômé
Collège de génie civil, et aujourd'hui je suis en formation
Les enfants veulent danser, surtout ceux qui...
Ils ont traversé de nombreuses périodes difficiles dans leur vie, notamment
Par la guerre
[musique]
[applaudissements]
doux
Il nous est venu
[musique]
C'est là que se trouvaient l'Etat islamique et Jabhat al-Nosra à Alep
Vieux
Et ils ne sortaient pas, mais ils augmentaient
Des bombes sur le monde, c'est-à-dire le monde que vous habitez
Pour la faim, je veux dire, d'ailleurs
L'armée a été contrainte d'exploser avec l'armée russe
Ces histoires jusqu'à ce qu'ils puissent les raconter
[musique]
Ne me laisse pas tomber et ne me quitte pas
Ce que nous avons entendu à propos de la guerre, c'est que nous avons entendu de nombreux bruits
Il y avait beaucoup de bruits violents, il y avait beaucoup
Des voix fortes
[musique]
Nous dormions, ne nous sentions pas en sécurité, ne savions pas s'il était parti
Le missile vient vers nous, comme Halbit ou O
Ne signifie pas
[musique]
C'était très difficile, la guerre était très difficile pour nous
Le plus difficile, ce sont les martyrs et les gens qui...
Les gens qui écoutaient mouraient
Dans les rues, des enfants qui mouraient
Sur le chemin de l'école, cette chose s'est produite
C'est très difficile pour nous
[musique]
C'est un peu difficile parce que tu danses au milieu de la destruction
Peut-être que cette zone d'Alep est plus grande que
J'ai mangé un hit, je veux dire
Vous racontez l'histoire de nombreuses personnes gratifiantes
C'est important ici le pays
Je ne peux pas dire que c'est un sentiment doux, doux, et ce n'est pas seulement doux
Le temps est doux
Dans la vie c'est possible
Si Dieu le veut, Seigneur, tout redeviendra comme avant
Cela pourrait être ça
Allez, prêt
[musique]
ce travail
Son nom est aussi le pouvoir du destin
Immédiatement
[musique]
[applaudissements]
En espagnol
[musique]
Sur cet endroit et cet endroit
Tu as un mur de séparation
Entre destruction et guerre
[musique]
Et la civilisation
C'est ce que nous avons toujours espéré
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Je ne sais pas
Il est incroyable que cela puisse être
Ce destin est peut-être juste
[musique]
Est-il possible combien et combien avec
Le moment et la musique
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Bravo
[musique]
Dans une nouvelle violation de la souveraineté syro-israélienne
Des frappes sont lancées contre l'aéroport international d'Alep et la campagne de Damas
Le début fut la découverte d’Alep
Comment vas-tu?
C'est bon, je te jure qu'on est assis à boire du café.
Boire avec nous
Regarde ça, Baba
Comment vas-tu
Donne-le-moi
[applaudissements]
C'est bien, c'est quelque chose qui nous rend fiers
Ta séparation, oh
Faites toujours de l'exercice, l'exercice est interdit
Comment est votre situation au Liban ?
Aujourd'hui, ma famille, mon père et ma mère, ne sont plus comme ça
La première c'est qu'ils n'ont plus toute cette lune et toute cette énergie
Surtout après que mes sœurs, les filles, aient voyagé et soient parties
A Alep, tout a changé pour eux, même ma famille
La guerre était une époque de coups, ils le pensaient franchement
Plus optimiste qu'ils ne l'auraient jamais imaginé
Ils partent et quittent Alep
[musique]
tu as
Apportez une vigne avec vous
Bonjour mes sœurs, les filles, Sandy Rola, Rola Aisha
Au Liban, Sandy est allée à Erbil mais chez ma famille
Aujourd'hui, ils veulent sortir et vivre avec
Mes sœurs, tout ce qui les intéresse c'est que ça nous permette de nous rendormir
La famille se réunit et nous retournons tous vivre ensemble
Certains d'entre nous sont comme les premiers
Aujourd'hui, le monde n'est plus comme avant
Les gens qui se sentent fatigués et opprimés
Comme des âmes mortes et fatiguées, des fantômes
Des familles voyagent chaque jour à l’étranger
Pays
Les gens qui sont restés ici sont ceux qui sont emprisonnés
Avec leur douleur, leurs chagrins et leur douleur
[musique]
Comme les filles de mon âge dans la trentaine
Vous les trouvez vivant seuls, sans personne avec eux
Même s'ils ne peuvent pas vivre une histoire d'amour, c'est tout
Les jeunes ont voyagé
Il y a ici beaucoup d'histoires d'amour mourant pour mille et une raisons
Bien sûr, surtout la guerre et les conditions de vie
La crise économique que nous vivons quotidiennement
Le problème c'est que nos vies aujourd'hui sont au point mort
Complètement immobile, l'horizon est bloqué pour un avenir inconnu
Devant nous, que nous soyons des filles ou des gars, il y a du monde
Elle n'a plus de rêves, ni de projets, ni de vie normale
C'est pourquoi beaucoup de jeunes ont voyagé
[musique]
Bonjour gars
La paix soit sur toi, Hajji
Vertiges
Tu veux dire ici ?
Allons-y
presque
Ici à Alep
[musique]
Mais le temps presse
Ou surtout un classique, tu sais ce que je n'aime pas
Écoutez complètement complètement
Elle surveille le patient, alors je mets des écouteurs et j'essaye de m'isoler
Le monde entier écoute
Nous sommes habitués à toi, Maya, dans nos vies
[musique]
[Il rit]
Non, il y a un monde que tu ne comprends pas
Leurs classiques, par exemple
[musique]
C'est elle qui écoute les choses
Cela signifie que Dieu soit loué
Nous imaginons, Seigneur, ton intrusion
au contraire
[applaudissements]
Dieu soit loué, aujourd'hui je suis revenu vivre comme ça
Le premier et le meilleur est grâce aux dons, de préférence
Les bienfaiteurs et nous continuerons le voyage
Sol non
Et pour
[musique]
J'ai ma lessive prête, c'est-à-dire
[applaudissements]
Mon objectif est de faire progresser cette chorale à un niveau artistique
Musique humaine
Mon objectif est de les envoyer partout dans le monde
Ça vient d'un endroit ou ressemblons-nous
Je veux voir la scène suivante, qui est une rose
Nabta dans un désert
[musique]
Symboliquement, je les considère comme mes enfants
Je suis très fier de chacun d'eux car il est incroyable
En peu de temps, ils ont réussi à y parvenir
Le résultat est très important pour tous les membres
La chorale désormais présente est le groupe de jeunes d'élite
Et les filles
Maya est l'une d'entre elles. Maya est un garçon avec beaucoup de passion.
Ça fait plaisir de le voir au bout d'un moment et pas trop loin
Seul de
Des chanteurs importants parmi quelques-uns
Au niveau local
[musique]
le film
Les habitués signifient après que nous ayons répondu
Je veux dire, je lui souhaite bonne chance, mais c'est sûr
Ils perdront avec nous, car ce jour arrive
[musique]
Il est l'un des membres de la chorale. Aujourd'hui, il a décidé
Joseph nous quitte et poursuit ses études à l'étranger en Russie
Aujourd'hui, il attend un visa pour le Canada
Malheureusement, chaque jour nous perdons quelqu'un et quelque chose
Je sais qui restera avec nous à la fin
[musique]
Plus je vieillis, de jour en jour, plus je m'attache
Et plus à Alep dans cette ville, mes sœurs, les filles
Sandy et Rola ont décidé de quitter le pays et de vivre
Loin aujourd'hui, notre famille n'est pas comme la première fois
L'un voyage après l'autre, mais j'ai l'impression de partir
Jusqu'à la fin, la dernière personne sortait et fermait la porte
La ville derrière elle est la porte d'Alep, mais en ce moment j'ai l'impression
Je dois continuer et garder ton esprit jusqu'au dernier moment
Je resterai riche de toute passion
Jusqu'à ce que la lumière revienne et brille sur la fille
[musique]